DOESN'T LOOK LIKE SHE'S TRYING
TO CONVINCE THOSE SITTING ON THE
FENCE QUEST MENTORING IS NOW,
TONY SAYEGH.
I HATE MOOD QUESTIONS.
WHAT IS THE MOOD OF THE
WHITE HOUSE?
BUT COME ON, TELL US THE MOOD,
AND DON'T SPIN IT.
>> LAURA, WE HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENTLY CONFIDENT ALL
ALONG, BECAUSE THE ONE
FUNDAMENTAL AND MOST IMPORTANT
FACT OF THE CASE HAS NOT
CHANGED.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE NOTHING
WRONG, AND THE REASON PELOSI
COME AFTER SAYING THEY AMASSED
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE DURING THE
HOUSE HEARINGS, SAYING THE
PRESIDENT, AND ONE OF THE
ARTICLES, WAS A REAL, CLEAR, AND
PRESENT DANGER TO THE COUNTRY.
THE REASON SHE HELD IT FOR A
MONTH IS BECAUSE SHE KNEW, SHE
PANICKED, THAT HER CASE WAS WEAK
THERE FOR YOU ARE AN ATTORNEY.
IF YOU HAVE A STRONG CASE, WOULD
YOU BE SAYING, AFTER CLOSING
INVESTIGATION, WAIT A MINUTE, WE
NEED MORE WITNESSES?
WAIT A MINUTE, WE NEED MORE
DOCUMENTS?
NO MATTER WHAT YOU THINK THE
QUALIFICATION OF THE MANAGERS
ARE, THE BOTTOM LINE IS THEY
HAVE A FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED
CASE, THAT IS MEANT TO BE
EXPOSED IN THE SENATE TRIAL,
WHICH WE KNOW IS GOING TO OFFER
A MUCH MORE FAIR PROCESS FOR OUR
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S OFFICE,
WITH PAT CIPOLLONE AND HIS TEAM,
BEING ABLE TO ACTUALLY TELL THE
PRESIDENT'S SIDE OF STORY IN A
FAIR, OPEN, TRANSPARENT WAY.
WE FEEL VERY STRONGLY IN THE
STRENGTH OF OUR CASE, AND WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE IT IN THE SENATE.
>> Laura: OKAY, SPEAKING OF
THEATRICS AND MOOD, THE PARADE
OF MANAGERS WALK THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT OVER TO THE SENATE.
THE MEDIA COVERING IT, IT WAS
LIKE O.J. AND THE WHITE BRONCO.
HERE COME THE ARTICLES.
THIS BIG, BLACK FOLDER.
DOESN'T IT LOOK LIKE A FUNERAL
DIRGE FOR THE DEMOCRAT PARTY?
>> WELL, THEY ARE MARCHING THE
TWO WEAKEST ARTICLES
TWO WEAKEST IRTICLES
TWO WEAKEST INTICLES
TWO WEAKEST IN TCLES
TWO WEAKEST IN THEES
TWO WEAKEST IN THE HISTORY OF
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: A FUNERAL DIRGE
PLAYING IN THE BACKGROUND.
IT'S AWAKE THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
IT WAS A LITTLE BLACK CASKET IN
FRONT, HOLDING THE ARTICLES.
>> SHE ALREADY MARCHED HER
CARCASS OFF THE CLIFF, LAURA.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY PAY THE
POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES OF NEXT
YEAR, MANY PEOPLE HAVE REASON TO
BELIEVE THEY WILL COME AS YET TO
BE SEEN.
THE REALITY AS IT IS GOING TO GO
TO THE SENATE, WHERE THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO RIG THE
PROCESS, SO THEREFORE, THE ONLY
WIN WHEN I GET TO RIG THE
PROCESS, AS THEY DID IN THE
HOUSE.
>> Laura: EVEN CNN WASN'T
BUYING THE SERIOUSNESS AND THE
HISTORIC NATURE OF ALL OF THIS
WITH THE THEATRICS.
WATCH.
>> IT WAS UNUSUAL TO SEE THAT
KIND OF CEREMONY AND HEADING OUT
THE PENS AND SMILING FOR A
PICTURE IN THIS KIND OF
SITUATION.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS A LITTLE
JARRING, AND CERTAINLY OFF
MESSAGE.
YOU ARE NANCY PELOSI THERE,
SAYING THIS WAS A SAD AND TRAGIC
DAY, AND THEN THERE SHE IS,
HOLDING UP THE PEN AND HAVING
PHOTOGRAPHS TAKEN.
>> Laura: I'M SURPRISED THEY
ARE BOTH STILL WORKING AT CNN
TONIGHT AFTER SAYING THAT.
>> THAT'S FINALLY CORRECT
ANALYSIS.
SHE ALSO FIST PUMPED TODAY WHEN
SHE WAS ON THE HOUSE FLOOR, AND
SOMEONE HAD REPEATED THAT
DONALD TRUMP NOW IS IMPEACH
FOREVER.
>> Laura: MY OTHER FAVORITE
ONE, BIAS.
>> WHICH REVEALS WHAT WE HAVE
KNOWN ALL ALONG, THIS IS A
POLITICAL VENDETTA.
THIS IS NOT A CONSTITUTIONALLY
MANDATED IMPEACHMENT BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT COMMITTED ANY SORT OF
HIGH CRIME OR MISDEMEANOR.
THIS IS ALL BORN OUT OF AN
ELECTION LOST IN 2016 AND A FEAR
OF AN ELECTION LOSS IN 2020 IF
THEY DON'T TRY TO DELEGITIMIZE
THE PRESIDENT.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY DON'T HAVE A
CASE.
>> Laura: THE SENATE DOESN'T
ALLOW ALL OF THE NEW EVIDENCE,
NEW WITNESSES AND TEXT MESSAGES
AND TWEETS AND SMOKE SIGNALS IN,
THEN IT IS JUST A COVER UP IN
THE SENATE.
THEY ARE ALREADY SETTING UP, IF
McCONNELL SAYS NO MAS, WE ARE
NOT DOING THIS, IT'S A COVER-UP.
SPEAK OF AFTER DELEGITIMIZE THE
PROCESS BECAUSE IT WILL BE A LOT
MORE FAIR AND THEY CAN'T RIG IT.
IF YOU WANT ALL OF THESE
WITNESSES, YOU HAVE THE POWER IN
THE HOUSE TO INTRODUCE ALL OF
THIS EVIDENCE, IN THE HOUSE
PROCESS.
THEIR PLAYING GAMES, AND THEY
KNOW IT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS WAS
NEVER DESIGNED TO LEAD TO A
REMOVAL OF THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS DESIGNED TO POLITICALLY
HURT THE PRESIDENT, BUT A